c'était comme un mauvais présage
les choses ont bien mal commencé quand
justin trudeau est d'arriver au palais
du peuple
un caméraman de radio-canada dûment
accrédités a été bousculé par les agents
de sécurité chinois la poignée de main
est égal chez l'attention bien visible
autour de la table le froid a persisté
la rencontre s'est prolongée et
finalement les signes sont devenus
réalité mal à l'aise les deux leaders
ont annoncé que les négociations de
libre-échange n'aurait pas lieu pour
l'instant nous croyons que lorsque tout
est fait correctement un accord
commercial est avantage pour chacun des
pays en cause restant plutôt vague le
premier ministre chinois a évoqué des
divergences d'opinion entre les deux
pays sur certains enjeux sans
explication la séance de questions des
journalistes a été annulée par le
gouvernement chinois
justin trudeau a tenu son propre point
de presse pour expliquer ce qui venait
de se passer pour nous on a des attentes
élevées comme les canadiens ont des
attentes élevées
le premier ministre avait mis la barre
haute il voulait négocier un accord
progressistes avec des normes élevées
sur le plan du travail de
l'environnement de la gouvernance et de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
ces exigences semblent avoir creusé un
fossé que les chinois n'étaient pas
prêts à traverser est la chesnaie
ouverte mais continua
à regarder comment ça pourrait
fonctionner parce que évidemment on
parle d'un grand précédent pour eux d'un
accord avec un pays du g7
ce revers commence bien mal un voyage
qui a pour but de resserrer les liens
économiques avec la chine
l'image est d'autant plus embarrassante
pour justin trudeau
lui qui aime se présenter comme le
champion du libre échange pour l'instant
l'idéal du premier ministre est
confronté à un géant qui ne se laisse
pas bousculer ici louis blouin
radio-canada à pékin